So the hypothalamus is is an entity,
it's a group of functionally related entities that are composed of groups of
functionally related entities,
but you know you can't start at the highest level of detail and progress
forward.
So we're going to use shortcuts.
So anyways,
the hypothalamus isn't a very big brain area but it's an important one and it's
sufficiently sophisticated so that if you take a female cat and that there's an
important reason that it's female and you take out basically it's whole brain,
the limbic system that's responsible for emotions and the whole cortical cap.
So it basically has no brain except for his final chord.
The hypothalamus.
And if you keep it in a relatively closed environment you don't like like a
cage,
it pretty much acts like a normal cat.
It can do all the normal cat things.
It can,
it can engage in defensive aggression,
it can eat,
it can drink,
it can sleep.
It's Co,
it's conscious as you know in so far as you can tell whether or not an animal is
conscious,
it's hyper exploratory,
which is extraordinarily peculiar because last thing you would expect of a cap
with no brain would be to be hyper exploratory.
Right?
It seems to be insanely curious about everything and that's what that seems to
indicate is that it's psychomotor exploratory system,
which is in fact grounded in the hypothalamus is still active,
but it can't build up the memory representations that would inhibit the
exploratory activity because basically what you're doing when you explore is
you're taking something,
something complex and then your mapping.
It's responses in relationship to the transformations of your body and in so far
as the set of transformations of your body that you're likely to manifest,
say in this place,
have zero motivational relevance,
which is really what you're hoping for most of the time.
Then you build up a representation of the place that's,
that's part of that perceptual motor hierarchy and it shuts off your curiosity
about it and then what you perceive from then on end really is your
representation of the thing.
Rather than the thing itself.
And you're kind of happy about that because it's easier to see what you've
already learned that it is to see that thing itself.
Now things can get re novelized you know,
if someone acts very peculiarly right beside you,
you're like the whole space around you is going to get re novelized very rapidly
and your body would go on alert because of that.
But Mick,
basically what you're doing is learning in order to ignore,
right?
Because you want,
you want to pay attention to everything all the time.
It's like that's,
that's a short path to exhaustion because if everything's relevant than your
body goes on hyper alert and you produce cortisol and you know,
you're ready for anything and there's,
that's kind of exciting.
But as a longterm survival strategy,
it's bad.
What you just don't have the energy to maintain that for any length of time.
So part of the reason the cat is hyper exploratory is because the systems that
mediate exploration are still intact as long as it has a hypothalamus and some
of the rough underlying circuitry that associates that with the motor output
system.
Um,
but I can't remember what it's explored.
So just stays hyper exploratory.
It's also hyper reactive safety cues of aggression.
I would say like a hypothalamic cat is a lot like a two year old,
you know,
and I mean that in the best possible way.
Um,
two year olds are extremely curious.
They're hyper exploratory.
They're very,
very reactive to stimuli.
You know,
they cry easily,
they laugh easily,
they run around easily.
They,
they get scared easily.
you know,
experienced pain easily.
So,
and it isn't until they build the higher order structures in the,
in the,
you know,
perceptual motor hierarchy that that all gets integrated and they're not so
reactive then they're nowhere near as much fun at that point either,
you know,
but uh,
and so the female cat can,
can regulate its,
its water intake and it can also engage in sexual activity.
Now a male cat can't do that.
It needs more brain than just the hypothalamus because it's more complicated to
sequence male sexual behavior.
So you can tell the difference between a male cat with no court tax,
let's say it,
no limbic system and a female cat,
but pretty much only in that,
in that particularity.
So,
so,
you know,
so that's very interesting.
A,
because if you,
if you study neuropsychology and you're taught by clinical neuropsychologist,
say,
or even neuropsychologists that have a clinical background,
they're very cortical centric.
You know,
and I think it's,
it's part of your hangover.
We're,
we're,
you know,
since we got unseated from our position at the center of the universe,
we've been,
you know,
rat rat radically running around trying to figure out what it is that makes us
special in relationship to animals.
And we kind of cottoned onto the idea that,
you know,
we have this big cortical cap and especially the prefrontal Cortex,
and it's very large in relationship to our body,
which,
which it is.
And that,
you know,
somehow that distinguishes us from other animals,
which it does.
But,
but that's also led us into thinking that the most recently evolved parts of the
brain are the most important.
It's like,
and,
and in some sense the smartest,
you know?
But there's a real error of presumption there because you might also,
you might think instead that it's those parts of the brain that evolution has
had the longest time to work on that are in fact the smartest,
you know?
And they do take care of all the heavy lifting.
You know,
your,
your consciousness isn't entrusted with any of the heavy lifting.
You can fiddle around the edges with it,
but you're not going to be allowed to do anything that's really PR,
you know,
that's really physiologically profound.
And it's a good thing because you just don't have the intellectual capacity to
manage that kind of ongoing physiological monitoring.
You know?
It's like you don't understand your body if you're lucky,
the thing works and you can ignore it roughly speaking,
you know?
But if it ever goes wrong,
good luck trying to figure it out consciously.
You know?
I mean,
we're getting somewhere with that,
but it's very,
very difficult to do.